early on the communists did something
really really smart they focused on
education they focused on the next
generation coming up and they they
trained a whole bunch of uh teachers in
the in in the new ideology
uh
and uh
and we we got an excellent academic
education but we also got a phenomenal
amount of indoctrination okay so uh
communist ideology uh
was involved in with almost everything
you were doing regardless of what it was
it could have been sports or
theater
uh
the arts and of course school
so i grew up
with the firm knowledge a that there was
no god and b that uh
communism was the future of the world
and that we it was our responsibility as
the next generation
to
precipitate the move from the bat system
that was in the west like all the not
the old nazis and the and the bad
capitalists and
and eradicate poverty in the world so we
could finally establish
paradise on earth for the working class
i bought into this it was probably
next to impossible not to there were
some dissidents but typically there were
people who
had a glimpse of the other world the
west they had like people who came over
relatives
and they came over and they brought nice
presents they brought oranges which we
i didn't see until maybe i was 10 years
old
and so they started looking a little bit
i had no
i hadn't we had no such connection and i
had no reason to look
um particularly as i
entered college um i was a pretty smart
kid
and as i entered college in my first
year i established a reputation of being
the best
and in the next couple of years
uh i enhanced that reputation to an
extent that i already had a name for
myself
and i was it was quite clear that i was
i wasn't thinking really class ruling
class i would but i was going to be one
of the people that
you know helped everybody else that were
not quite as smart to live a good life
so i i never really investigated uh
you know
the potential truth or not elect thereof
of our ideology our our history i just
believed it because it was good for me
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye